uh well let's head to Manchester where
we'll find Andrew gwendy Shadow Minister
for Public Health Mr Gwen lovely to see
you this morning and we will talk of
course about about your brief
specifically in in just a second but in
terms of those strikes on the railways
discussions with the rmt appear to have
broken down four days of of strikes are
now looming where do we go from here
well I think it's incumbent on the
transport secretary to sit down and
negotiate a deal
um the fact that the transport secretary
a bit like the health secretary has
refused to do that is what has led to
this uh situation over Christmas and
ultimately
um the public will now be worried about
whether their Christmas
arrangements are in turmoil the
government's really got to get a grip of
this and that starts by sitting down
negotiating and coming up with some kind
of compromise that both sides can live
with
but but in terms of the matter rather
closer to your brief um nurses and and
the prospect of them going on strike I
mean are the pay Rises that they are
asking for affordable
well look uh I've not seen uh the the
books uh Beyond what's in the public
domain they probably aren't but again
it's that refusal of the government to
speak to the health unions and this has
been going on since the summer that
refusal to negotiate
um has caused this problem there were no
strikes in the NHS during the 13 years
of the previous labor government
um and that's because we had good
working relationships not just with the
unions but with the workforce across the
NHS I still think it's possible to avert
strikes in the NHS if the health
secretary will sit down negotiate with
nurses because look patients already
can't be treated on time and strike
action is the last thing we need yet the
government's letting this happen and I
don't think patients will ever forgive
the conservatives for this dereliction
of Duty sure but but to be absolutely
clear just like the conservatives you're
not promising inflation busting pay
Rises
well we're not paying that we we afford
what the unions are asking for but a
negotiation is just that you sit down
you listen to the issues you listen to
the concerns on both sides you come up
uh with uh common areas to agree and
ultimately you come out with a deal the
government's not doing that we would do
that we would sit down with the uh the
employers representatives and we would
ensure that we averted these strikes as
I say we didn't have a single strike in
the NHS under the last Labor government
there's no reason why there should be
one under this conservative government
but part of the problem that strikes me
as regards to the situation with nurses
and indeed with with the rmt is the
original offers that were made were
based on data collected quite some time
ago the offer was made at a point where
you know inflation was running in the
low single digits rather than where it
is at the moment I just wonder whether
or not labor would be minded to push
forward with some at review of this
independent uh pay body to make it a
little bit more contemporaneous with the
economic circumstances that that we're
in at the moment you would be get that
nurses would have had a far more
significant pay offer um from the
government if that were the case well
look labor will always defend the rights
of working people and that includes the
right to organize and the right to
withdraw your labor and and these are
fundamental rights But ultimately the
the situation that you set out Neil is
precisely the kind of thing that you sit
around the table and you discuss and you
come to some kind of agreement on both
sides that may well be something that
needs to be put on the table and that
Steve Barkley as the health secretary
should take Serious consideration of
because ultimately we need to avert
these strikes in the NHS because
ensuring as many patients as possible
can receive the care that they need must
be a priority this winter given that so
many
um operations are being canceled in the
NHS right now just a word then and from
you Mr Gwen about the use of military
personnel during an ambulance workers
strike the story in the front of the
newspapers this morning that taxi
drivers could be drafted in to get
people to hospital
look that's a sign of failure and I hope
the government can avert all of this all
they need to do is to sit down round the
table with the representatives of the
trade unions come up with some
compromise agreement and let's get our
NHS working again
when you say get the NHS working again
there does appear to have been a fairly
significant change in tone from the
labor party as regards the NHS I mean
we're streating seeing just the other
day at the health services it is not a
shrine I mean do you agree with that and
and if so can you explain exactly what
he means
well look I think what Wes means is that
the NHS was founded in 1948 it's guiding
principles are as relevant today as they
were back then but it's not some
monolith that doesn't change that set in
aspect it changes throughout the needs
of uh history so you know the NHS of
1948 was very different in 1968 very
different in 1998 and will be different
in the future that will come with
investment from the the labor government
we are committed to a Workforce plan we
are committed to getting those waiting
times and waiting lists down and we are
committed to new technology
you're not comparing where Street denied
Bevan are you
absolutely I I think that West streeting
will be the modern eye Bevin under the
next Labor government changing the NHS
making it modern making it relevant for
the future for important getting better
outcomes for patients new treatments new
technologies and better outcomes that's
what has to happen and with every penny
of investment we have to make sure
there's a return for that we have to
make sure that the productivity is there
we have to make sure that those waiting
times and waiting lists come down it's
only meal what we did uh in the previous
labor government we got the NHS back on
its feet after uh the previous
conservative government had shattered it
we want to do that again we want to make
the NHS fit for purpose fit for the 21st
century